how dare sequencing a human genome at
the start of the century cost three
billion dollars but after the cost of
sequencing plummeted we have sequence
thousands of individual human genomes
for a fraction of the original course in
a few years you may even get your genome
sequence at the doctor's office as a
routine medical procedure the dream is
that the affordability of DNA sequencing
will soon allow us to sequence the
genome of every human being in order to
identify the genetic basis of many
diseases including cancer and start
working on personalized treatments but
how can we find the mutations that make
your genome different from my Gina onion
turtle chip in this class we will learn
about lighting fast algorithm that can
determine how your genome differ from my
and Phillips in one of this algorithm is
based on an ingenious file compression
method introduced by researchers who
never imagined it would be used to find
disease-causing mutations we're also
going to discuss a disease that has
resisted all efforts to eradicate it HIV
the key reason why we still don't have
an HIV vaccine is because HIV mutates so
rapidly that it is winning the war
against vaccine developers as a result
of its many mutations HIV is not a
single virus instead it comprises
several different types that cross the
species barrier from monkeys to humans
at different points during the 20th
century and that continued to evolve
today a single vaccine for HIV will
likely continue to evade us therefore we
need an algorithm for accurately
comparing and classifying different
types of HIV in order to design tailored
drug cocktails for specific patients if
faced a similar problem when we compare
related proteins in diverged species
separated by millions of years of
evolution figuring out the elusive
similarity between such proteins is a
challenge
to address this challenge we will learn
about sequence comparison Algar it's
powered by a machine learning paradigm
called a hidden Markov model along the
way we will encounter another scientist
who had no clue that zalgar it he
developed for speech recognition half a
century ago would become widely used for
finding subtle similarity between
diverged proteins to learn about hidden
Markov models we're going to need to
take a trip back in time to go gambling
with the Yakuza we hope that you're
gonna take the risk with us and join us
although these instructors may appear
crazy they are not quite as mad as they
look dr. Pavel PES Nair is a
distinguished professor of computer
science at the University of California
San Diego and a leading authority on
bioinformatics he's dressed this way
because he sometimes thinks that he's a
sheriff of bioinformatics
a frontier discipline underpinning the
digital revolution in biology and
personalized medicine dr. Phillip Campo
is an assistant professor of computer
science at Carnegie Mellon University to
learn why he is dressed this way you'll
need to take this course or read the
textbook bioinformatics algorithms and
active learning approach co-authored by
the two speakers